okay
they're not purple not purple these
so um
so yeah so you've been involved with
calendars quite a bit right
yes and since when since 1993
okay so when you first started you know
talk to me about
what was there what were your challenges
what was happening in the industry
everything and so on so 1983 i was in
i.t
i wasn't a vendor and i was at a typical
mid-sized company growing
and we were using file sharing based
email
and we had not had any sort of
historical legacy
mainframe systems we were never on profs
or anything like that
and we just had grown up this email
culture and as we were growing as a
company
uh you couldn't just go to go down the
hall and say let's have a meeting
it had to start getting a formalized
structure from
when it was 200 people in one building
to a thousand people across the campus
so were people using electronic
calendars then
not really there was a lot of filofax
and you know whatever day timers and the
like
and on paper yeah and um
uh you know email to try to coordinate
calendars but but that was that was
pretty much it in that company
some of the very earliest pdas were just
starting to come out
so the hp 95 lx was like one of the
first
handheld flip up devices that had
ccmail built into it some people had
palm pilots or palms that they they were
just palms at the time
and you know we're starting to use that
but really for the most part
electronic calendaring wasn't in the
environment it wasn't
in the workplace unless you had been in
a big company that had ibm props
and a mainframe that was kind of the
only so those people were used to oh
yeah well i'll have my calendars just
now my system that wasn't
a good calendar but it was their closed
environment
we didn't have any of that okay and none
of the file sharing vendors had any kind
of
uh calendaring service as part of their
email systems there was nothing with
ccmail there was nothing with microsoft
mail
word perfect office eventually added
calendar but it wasn't
it wasn't initially there either so the
industry in the early 90s was just
starting to recognize calendaring
lotus acquired a company called threads
in the uk
and they made the organizer and so lotus
had this pim product lotus organizer and
then they undertook in 93 the
engineering
to make lotus organizer a group calendar
product okay
and as a ccmail customer with these kind
of problems in our business
we were extremely interested in what
lotus was going to do there
microsoft also started doing with
schedule plus
some added to microsoft mail and
you know so it sort of got born in the
distributed environment
93 time frame so why do you think the
counter was
merged with mail i think transport
was really the main reason everybody
already got email
in the organization so it was the only
system in most companies that touched
everyone
and if i could piggyback on that to do
some other business workflow
especially something as horizontal as
calendaring i think that that was
probably the logic
and in fact the early versions of lotus
organizer didn't
do anything in the mail system your
invites and all that stuff were
separate when you launched lotus
organizer you saw them
but they were called out of your inbox
by the organizer program
essentially as a hack right it would go
into your inbox and look for
keywords and pull those over into lotus
organizer but you did all your
workflow and calendaring stuff in the
calendar that it wasn't like
you were in your inbox and saw an
invitation okay
i just want to see if it gets working
all right
actually this is good by the way i
didn't even know that the early versions
of
a calendar were actually separated
from the mail it just used males to
transport that was all it was and it was
and also i guess it's a good
distribution channel right
you basically say well if i want to get
calendar in the hands of a lot of people
at the end of the day
put it with the mail right well and it
had a directory already yeah that was
that
you know but the individual calendars
were individual files
they weren't in any kind of shared
database they had to go on an h drive on
the network or whatever
so but it was a it was it was a it was a
single file that was my
org or or2 or whatever and i could
copy that to my local drive if i was
working on it at home or on a laptop or
whatever
not that everybody had laptops at that
time either but
you know not many at all did yeah but it
was
very single user-centric and very
um clutching it just was yeah but
but it somehow worked okay and then from
so so then
what was the next logical step from
there so then in uh
kind of the mid 90s is when um the
client server messaging era sort of
started to take off with lotus with
notes before
and microsoft with exchange right
and exchange 96 original industries in a
microsoft mail client
but then in out they introduced outlook
in 97
helping themselves and that was a
combined mail and calendar client
and lotus introduced notes 4.5
with an integrated calendar that we had
based loosely
on the features of organizer uh in 1997.
we also made organizer work on top of
notes
what were what were customers saying
like
back then like calendaring became a
a requirement driven by it by i see yeah
yeah just as a this is another service
we want to provide
as part of our enterprise communications
infrastructure
now that we see the technology is
available we want it and we want it in
this environment
and a lot of companies that had never
gone through a file sharing based email
system
we're still on mainframes we're on profs
we're on
deck all-in-one you know all these other
sort of prior generation mail systems
that it had calendaring
so they were like well if i'm going to
move to client server it's got to have a
calendar
so that was really the impetus for us to
get that into the product
uh in the 96.97 time frame
okay and then so that so that calendar
that you started to put in there
um like when did it become
uh when did the switch happen from
saying okay it's my calendar
versus i want to start sharing it with
other people when the
and what was the reason people started
to want to calendar share
um i think that some corporate cultures
really drove the idea that i want to i
want everybody
to be able to see what my calendar is my
department i want to be able to choose
people to know where i'm at
there were heart the mechanisms weren't
easy to distribute that information any
other way
most of the email systems didn't even
have an out of the office kind of a
function at that point not an effective
one
so you know putting my calendar online
was an easy way to tell
my work group or my department or my
building or whatever
where i was and and even the earliest
versions of
notes and outlook had some level of
privacy controls or whatever that i
could just publish free time or i could
just publish my calendar or whatever
and i think that the organizational need
was just to be able to know where people
were
as companies sort of that were
distributed across multiple sites
uh started to work together more using
other
current generation collaborative tools
okay
and and did that need then evolve into
something else after that or or was it
really
i want to know what people in my
organization are doing
i think the evolution from there was
how do i schedule conference rooms how
do i think about
really truly doing meetings this way and
not just
personal diary info how do i sync that
to something that's a
local device of some kind or at least
have access to it at home
so the usage patterns did definitely
change
from the initial you know sort of our
4.5 release
okay to now the the use of calendaring
has become
part and parcel of every deployment you
know for a while there we introduced it
about half customers said we're not
going to use that we're just using it as
an email system
but we have apps but calendaring now in
i think pretty much every notes customer
uses the calendar
i'm sure that outlook users would say
exactly the same thing
if you forward it if you forward to now
or the present or maybe
in the future i don't know do you see
that the calendar
can exist by itself
or does it need to be with the email
system i think the calendar
a few years ago probably hit an
inflection point where it was
distinct from the email there's some
things like uh
directory lookup or whatever that it
needs to sort of rely on the same
infrastructure
but in some ways my calendar has its
extensions now instead of to email to
uh online meetings right if i'm going to
have an online meeting i have a single
click
link to initiate that and start meeting
and whatever
presence and awareness so my instant
messaging kind of environment
so i can see if the people i invited to
this meeting are online right now and if
they're going to
show up to the meeting whether they
accept it or not
i can have a side chat going i can
whiteboard with them i can you know i
could do voice over ip
so i think it's more that the calendars
actually become
a center of work as opposed to it being
an adjunct to the mail system
what it hasn't done yet and what we and
probably other companies look at pretty
extensively in research is
how do i use the calendar to more
effectively manage my day as opposed to
my day being managed by the calendar
and i think that's still one of the
biggest challenges with the email and
calendar and
all the collaborative tools is how do i
as the individual
knowledge worker decide what i want to
do every day
and not just come in and say here's the
things that are going to happen today
based on my calendar so what do you see
happening there like yeah
what tools can be built or what what can
happen there so
you know our research team likes to talk
about social analytics they like to talk
about looking at your environment for
cues as to what's most important
so one of the things we're working on
under the the banner project volca
is the notion that if i have a 30 minute
block of time
that isn't in a scheduled meeting the
system is going to bubble up for me
five or six tasks activities i don't
know what right word to put on it
uh informational bullets things that i
should do in this 20 minutes
because there are things going on in the
environment right now
they're time sensitive things like an
expense report approval
you know how do i want to best use my
spare time outside of meetings and then
when i am in a meeting
have i invited the right people based on
the subject matter of the meeting
are we doing the right document sharing
do we have the minutes being captured in
an activity
so it needs to become more of a
focusing effort on the work product
and i've actually i i guess i've kind of
been beating this drum for years and the
technology is now going in this
direction of
i don't want to be reactive all day i
don't want to just sit there and say oh
what's next on my calendar
oh now i have to start thinking about
this i want to be going
all day with here's what i'm thinking
about here's what i'm trying to
accomplish today
and have the tools help me get those
done interesting and
and how do you see or is there a
like is there a um a fit like
what's your vision about you know
there's all these buzz about location
based services and it's telling you
where you are at this moment
and so on like is there a tie-in with
the calendar and your opinion on this
and how
what's your yeah so i mean we've already
taken one step in that direction by
being
by linking uh presence awareness with
calendar so my calendar already knows if
i've got a scheduled meeting to put
me on that status automatically
as the clock strikes 10 30. and it's
going to grab
from my presence awareness what location
i've defined i'm that i'm at
and in the lotus same time world we have
that set up you know it can even be ip
address based
that when you log in say here from an
ibm office
that it already knows where you are it's
identifying that and knows what the best
way to contact you is going to be
based on your system profiles so we're
kind of halfway there
the rest of the way there that i think a
lot of people are trying to solve is
who's around me that might be
useful for ad hoc collaboration
maybe i'm already having a meeting about
project purple and
there's a project purple staff member
who's in the same facility i'm in
uh right now but they weren't on the
invite list for this meeting but maybe
they have something to contribute we
kind of go
sort of grab them from their location
awareness and
pull them into a work product or
you know the more random i'm in an
airport and
one of my business partners is in the
same airport and boy we both have an
hour delay on our flight
shouldn't we go grab a beer